I called you here today because we face  dire circumstances our intelligence has  confirmed the existence of a new threat  that is unlike any we have seen before  this organization has the ability to  carry out attacks anywhere in the world  they are highly lethal and  indiscriminant of age religion or  nationality the potential for loss of  human life and psychological terror is  substantial and cannot be ignored  they are the very definition of an  unknown quantity  our early choice of action is to meet  force with force as of this moment my  program is reactivated and I am handing  over command of all global field  operations to recruit the operators from  among the world's foremost elite orders  and protocols are irrelevant  be the shield that safeguards the  civilized world from those who wish to  do in harm no matter how or where our  enemies strike no matter what defends  they cower behind team rainbow must  stand ready  you  you